when you are working in chimera you will
usually be visualizing protein
structures
however it is also possible to visualize
structures containing both protein and
nucleic acid components
for example here we have the pdb entry 1
hys a reverse transcriptase enzyme from
hiv
to change the depiction of the
nucleotides that the enzyme is holding
we can go to actions atoms and bonds and
nucleotide objects
under settings we see a panel containing
the various depiction options
for example under the side chain section
we can change the fill slash slab to
ladder
now
the slabs are replaced with rods as
shown on screen
chimera contains many other useful
depiction options under the tools menu
for example under depiction we can color
the structure according to a rainbow
color scheme
i'm using the default color range as
shown here but you can customize your
own colors in the color editor
when we hit apply the structure is
colored according to the range set above
starting with blue at each n terminus
and ending with red at each c terminus
because this protein contains two chains
there are a total of four termini in the
structure two of which are highlighted
on screen
under tools and depiction we can also
color by secondary structure
if we apply the default settings
alpha helices are colored red beta
sheets purple and coils gray
notice that this coloration only applies
to the protein part of the structure not
the nucleic acids
here i have recolored the structure to a
more uniform color scheme to demonstrate
some of the advanced effects that
chimera has to offer
under actions and ribbon we can activate
ribbon edging
this gives the ribbons thicker and more
clearly defined edges
for more effect options we can go to
tools
viewing controls and open up the effects
panel
among the variety of effects shown here
is depth cueing
if we turn off depth cueing the
structure takes on a much flatter
appearance
you can also activate silhouettes which
give the structure a darker outline
you can adjust parameters such as width
and color
for the most clearly defined outlines
set the transparency under a all the way
up to 1
and change the color to black
finally you can turn on shadows for a
more three dimensional appearance
another interesting feature to explore
is the side view
using this feature you can slice through
the structure to determine how much of
it you will see
you can also use chimera to emulate the
distinctive art style that david
goodsale uses in his molecule of the
month column on pdb101
in the examples shown on screen we can
see that this style is characterized by
flat lighting and the use of individual
atoms as opposed to ribbons
to achieve this style the first step is
to go to tools
viewing controls and lighting
here we can change the lighting from its
default setting to ambient
this creates the distinctive flat look
with the lighting configured we can now
go to actions and show the atoms and
bonds
then we must hide the protein ribbons by
setting the selection mode to append
selecting chains a
and b
and under actions choosing ribbon hide
with the selection cleared we can change
the atoms and bonds depiction to sphere
the result bears some resemblance to the
art style of david goodsell
you can take this one step further by
going to actions
color and choosing by element
now each atom in the protein is colored
according to the standard elemental
coloration scheme